je m'appelle david j'ai 53 ans je suis
policier municipal responsable d'un
service de police une douzaine de
personnes
je fais ce métier depuis trente trois
ans maintenant mois principalement c'est
de gérer de futures visites organisées
les missions de la police municipale
après l'émission plus générale c'est
d'être sur le terrain de convenir de de
veiller à la tranquillité et à la
sécurité de notre commune
[Musique]
des attentes il y en a beaucoup mais
j'ai franchement j'en attends pas
beaucoup n'ont pas beaucoup parce que ça
fait des années et des années qu'on nous
fait des promesses
je parle comme un cadeau pour mon métier
fait des années qu'on nous fait des
promesses et
mais trente trois ans j'ai jamais rien
vu venir à part des lourds 10 mans de
compétences mes attentes c'est une vraie
prise en considération de la police
municipale ne conçoit pas des fois on
nous dit qu'on est la troisième force
public mais dans l'est dans les actes
il y a
malheureusement on ressent un
désintéressement l'augmentation de nos
prérogatives qui nous permet maintenant
de faire beau chaud ça c'est clair mais
malheureusement le volet social lui n'a
pas beaucoup augmenté
comparé nos collègues
du côté de la population genre à marie
e
notre retraite et les modiques et
une carrière complète
dans policiers ont par terriblement avec
1300 ou 1400 euros de retraite dans les
meilleurs moments